Hello, this is Steve, and today I would like to
talk about this language test.I
think the most famous language proficiency tests in Japan are probably A and Kama Toy.The
other day, I read a lot of things on the Internet.  When I looked into it, I found out that a
new English test system from a large American publishing company, or a publishing company that produces educational textbooks,
has been approved by the American education authorities, and along with that, I found out that the
Tuna Soldiers were born.  Now it's possible to sell a lot of books,
because of the level of each test, you
can sell more than a certain amount of books and CDs.They're
not cheap.Books and CDs cost 80 yen.  You
need $, right? So when I went to
Japan the other day, when I
went to a bookstore and looked at all the books for studying English and other foreign languages, I took a
test.  There are the most books about
tofu tofu, Aia, and everyone else who
seems to be only thinking about tests,
right? But that English, not just that English,
but that word. Where is the meaning of the word test?
Well, for example, I
speak the national language of the party, right?First of all, I have
never taken a Japanese test.I have never
taken a test.
So,
if you can communicate with Comiket, you
can speak it, you can read it, you can
understand it, and that's all you need.The language
itself is a natural thing, and speaking itself
is a very natural thing.
It's like walking, running, etc. And there's no need to test it, right
? Well, if you play
tennis, you'll
know who's playing if you play
tennis.  If the level is 4.2
or 6.5, that
doesn't mean anything to me.However,
that test is a big industry.
In my job, I have a lot of expertise, and I
form this committee, come to a conclusion,
discuss it again, conclude, report again, create it, send it out,
research it, read it, meet again,
have a meeting, etc.  So everyone
is busy, and then there are the tests,
and now it's time for advertising, sales activities,
and all kinds of advertising for schools and education in Tokyo,
and they're going to do
a lot of things in front of people.  Next time, I'll read the
book that came with that test, and I'll try to
master it by reading it a lot,
but the basic language is
Japanese.Japan is already the best in the world.
In Japan, there are over 2 million people taking tests every day and every year.What
about the level of English?It hasn't gotten any better because of it.Some
people with this ability are
able to communicate in English, or they
can't.  Well, if you talk like that, you'll be
able to understand things like that. If you do
n't have the opportunity to use that English,
and if the person in question doesn't have an interest in it, you won't be able to improve. You
won't get there.  First of all, if you weren't
interested in Japanese English to begin with, then
suddenly you have to go to a foreign country
or have a business relationship with a foreign company, and if you
start using English, you'll immediately
get better.  And I'm the same way myself.
One time I'll make a
mistake and say something wrong, and the next time I'll
say it correctly, and the next time I might say it wrong again.
Well, if you measure it with a
test, then the test
is just a picture of that person's verbal ability.
However, that is hardly correct, and the person's
ability is very fluid.  You know, sometimes you
get better, sometimes you get worse that day,
and so on. So
I really think that test
is a business, and the educational authorities, and
sometimes the employer.  That's right, I'm
asking for something like that, but in
reality, if the purpose is just
communication, it's
better to stop taking tests altogether.Instead, I want to
learn how to use the language.  The point is, how
can we do this so that both young people and adults want to study the language, or how
can we make it fun?
That's why,
rather than spending a lot of time on tests, you can
listen to all kinds of fun things, or you can
use the Internet to talk to people all over the world,
or use Skype to talk to
people.  I
think this is the best way to study for us, but the basics are the same: have
fun studying,
listen to and read interesting things, and
communicate with meaning,
think about your purpose,
and study the words.  Well, that's okay. That's
not the purpose of the test.
If the purpose is to test, then you
'll forget the real purpose. If that's the case, you can
stop toy testing, but
if that doesn't work, you'll have to do toy testing.  If
so, you have to do it.At least
study properly.Don't
study for the test.Don't study for the
test.Test and repeat.Don't practice.Instead,
improve your overall ability.Read
it.  Listen and
spend as much time as you can with the words,
read, listen, speak,
ignore the test, and do it that way, write, and you'll
get better results on the test,
even if you're a Link member, you'll only have 2 hours a day for 1 year, Link.  When I
heard this, I was a housewife,
but I listened to it while I was cooking, and as a result, my
Toys score increased by 300 points.I would like to
ask again for something like that in just one year.